my brother not my half-brother all my
bastard brother my brother it's your
choice
come on everybody it's Charlie this is
gonna be my Game of Thrones Season eight
episode for Q&A video so here we go
I pulled questions from my episode 4
video as well as the episode 5 trailer
video so we'll be covering a lot of
stuff because everyone's starting to
wonder about what's going on with the
finale if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Game of Thrones videos there's a new
round of the HBO now giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video there's
some new HBO footage that they dropped
this morning too that I'll tag at the
end of this just because it's not quite
related to what's going on with the
finale
obviously careful for spoilers through
episode 4 if you haven't seen it yet so
here we go first question cult-like
asks do you think that we're in store
for another wild fire explosion Emilia
Clarke hinted this on Jimmy Kimmel so I
know the interview that you're talking
about with Emilia Clarke that wasn't
exactly what she was talking about but I
do think there's gonna be a whole bunch
of fire before the producers seem to be
riding Mad Queen Daenerys so hard I
would have told you that wildfire might
be a big twist just because that's kind
of become Circe's weapon of trade and we
know the pyromancers are still a big
thing in King's Landing so it's possible
that there's more wildfire hidden
underneath the city but at the end of
last week's episode when Miss and I said
Dru chorus as her last words she was
actually speaking to Daenerys and as the
producers explained she was telling
Daenerys to quote/unquote light them up
because Dru chorus in high Valyrian
literally means Dragon Fire so I think
that most of the fire at least initially
is gonna come from Daenerys but this
will come up a lot in the next couple of
days while people are thinking about
what's gonna be happening during the
episode and what's happening with
Daenerys is Ark her small council tyrion
and varys right now are trying to get
her to not burn down King's Landing
during the attempt
next question Gemini Westworld asks so
does John want to be with her or not so
you talking about Daenerys yeah he
definitely wants to be with her but the
situation's become so complicated the
logic that the show is going with is
that Daenerys is worried that they won't
be able to be together if the realm
knows his true identity and knows that
they're related normally you think that
wouldn't be a big problem because why
wouldn't they just get married and they
Coe rule together and it's not a big
problem
Daenerys still gets the irons
rown just not in quite the way that she
expected but purred Daenerys is logic
and the way that the show is writing her
whether or not you agree with the way
that the show is writing her is that she
thinks that the other lords of the realm
will not support a marriage between the
two of them because they're related
now Varys mentioned it during the
episode she's his aunt of all the people
who know Jon Snow's secret and know
about his relationship with Daenerys
Varys is the only person who's ever
raised the issue that Jon Snow would not
want to get married to her because he's
so off put by the idea of them being
related even though for Daenerys it's
not that big of a thing you recognize
some of the problems with that logic too
because for hundreds of years
Targaryens Wed brother to sister they
ruled over Westeros and nobody in the
realm really had that big of a problem
with it so why then would the realm in
its current form not support a marriage
between Jon Snow and Daenerys it just
doesn't make a whole lot of sense we
will probably be analyzing a lot of the
plot twists in the last two episodes
thinking that very same thing but why is
this happening this doesn't make sense
based on the evidence that the show has
given us before and all the other stuff
they were foreshadowing so just be
prepared for illogical left turns next
one Starbuck stark asks how can brand
help in a war in the south ohshit old
brand that robb cannot be helped because
men cut down all the trees in the south
he gets his power from those trees so
the thing about that is that on the TV
show his power isn't quite so tied to
the weirwoods as it is in the books part
of the idea on the show is is that his
abilities when he's seeing through
history is he's actually seeing what the
weirwoods saw so how could he see
something if there wasn't a weirwood
there to see it so that's why people are
like well they're places in the south
where they cut all the weirwoods down so
he wouldn't be able to see history in
those places but as you saw in the TV
show he saw all that stuff happening
around the Tower of joy there are no
weirwoods in sight so clearly the show
doesn't care about that rule but really
I think brands importance will come in
in the finale when it comes time to
start thinking about how they're going
to rule Westeros going forward because
remember he remembers all this history
and things that have happened so one of
the immediate ways they could use him is
is to sort of prove what happened in the
north like when Jon Snow was talking
about the White Walkers how they
defeated them so he's very useful when
it comes to getting down to the truth
and facts about things in facts about
history next one's Erza casks will we
see the new Prince of Dorne his army and
soldiers from Highgarden
either Danny or John's aid when fighting
sir see I'm not expecting it but I do
think that we'll see that new Prince of
Dorne in the finale at some point
someone is gonna have to wind up winning
the game of Thrones whether or not
there's an Iron Throne at the end of all
this even though the ending is supposed
to be really bittersweet I do think I'll
have a way to reference what's going to
be happening with the future of things
so you'll have an idea for where the
characters and the realm is headed next
even if they don't spell it out in a
really great detail so they might pay
off that Prince of Dorne and have him
show up and whatever their final moments
are during the finale all the book
readers right now are scratching their
heads trying to figure out who that
Prince of Dorne is because they didn't
give him a name during the episode the
show was already killed off all the male
Martel's from the book so there are no
more heirs to take up their throne but
it could be some other they created for
the TV show or just some other secondary
character from the books that they've
given the throne to next question
paradox asks do you think that Dany is
gonna be pregnant or already is since
they kept talking about it last season
well yeah they certainly did foreshadow
it and going into this season I was kind
of expecting that but because we're in
the last couple of episodes and they
haven't said anything about it or
referenced it I am kind of wondering at
this point this all gets back to the
idea of the show setting up things and
then just completely taking left turns
try and be unexpected so I am a little
bit worried that they'll have set up all
these little plot points but it'll just
wind up being dead ends like no we don't
intend on paying that off like there was
a moment in the dragon pit in the season
7 finale where Jon Snow is talking to
Daenerys and she reminds him again she's
talked to him a couple times since
they've been together that she can't
have children anymore he drops this
really big teaser foreshadowing the
future saying maybe the woman who killed
your child in your husband isn't a
reliable source of information implying
that me remaster may have been trying to
miss leads and heiress or lie to her in
some way the books have provided a
little more evidence for this through
Dance with Dragons but since the TV show
has gone past that obviously they've
been a little more on the nose about it
I can't have children anymore Jon Snow
saying maybe she was lying to you when
was the last time she and Jon Snow had
sex how long has it been how much time
would pass before she could potentially
be showing the show plays it so fast and
loose with how much time goes by that
they really make it hard to connect the
dots and like I said they take a lot of
really big left turns a really good
example of an illogical Daenerys moment
from episode 4 is when they're having
that
war counsel moment in Johnson hotels are
all about the Ironborn fleet they talk
about it at length and then later when
Dan and Dave are talking about why ray
Gaal was killed
they say the Daenerys forgot about the
iron fleet when they were just talking
about it in the war Council in an
earlier scene so that doesn't make any
kind of sense so I am a little concerned
that there'll be moments like that
during Episode five and six but we'll
just have to see next question sue Heche
asks and one of brands visions a dragon
is flying over King's Landing is that
Danny riding drogon alone to the red
keep yeah they actually put that in one
of the season for trailers so long ago
they haven't done a lot of brands
visions in a while what happened was is
you just saw a shadow of a dragon flying
over King's Landing it wasn't on fire or
anything like that but this is way back
in season four and then I think they did
it again during season six when he's
flashing back and he sees the Mad King
you see him get a small vision of the
future with Cersei blowing up the great
Sept so he's seeing the past and the
future so as of right now I think that
that vision just implies Daenerys flying
over King's Landing which rogue on
during the big battle that's gonna be
happening during episode five next
question Amy asks do you think the
Brienne is pregnant with Jamie's child
do you think that he will die in her
arms well I would have said that before
like that when Jamie's like I want to
die in the arms of someone I love I was
thinking that that person would be
Brienne Nikolaj coster-waldau after
episode four came out and explained
Jaime's actions why he was going back to
King's Landing back to Cersei and why he
was not staying with Brienne a lot of
people were wondering if he was going
back to finally kill her and become the
queen Slayer like he's the King Slayer
would he also kill Cersei if she was
going to do something unimaginably
terrible during the big battle but as
much as it doesn't totally make sense
Nikolaj coster-waldau explained from a
script' perspective Jaime was going back
to Cersei because he's one
addicted to her like it's an addiction
and he's fallen off the wagon again like
he was briefly clean of her he was
having this happy life with Brienne and
he saw something that maybe he could
have for himself but like a lot of
addicts he falls off the wagon so he
feels like he's compelled he's pulled to
Cersei even though he understands how
bad she is but also at the same time
Nikolaj coster-waldau says that Jamie
doesn't think that he deserves a good
life with Brienne I'm a monster that's
why he kept saying that I'm terrible
I've done all these awful things I
pushed a boy out the window he basically
tells Brienne
all the worst things that he's ever done
so whether or not you think it's gonna
go down similarly in the books they
really needed a couple more episodes to
flesh out that relationship before Jamie
went back to Cersei to answer your
question about possible pregnancy no I
don't think the Brienne is praying it
with Jamie's child I think that would be
a little too much fanservice I think the
idea is the Jaime is gonna go out in a
blaze of glory so to speak with Cersei
in however it goes down they'll wind up
dying in each others arms and Brienne
will just be really sad about the whole
thing
next question Night Moves SSBs wouldn't
Iran be confused as to how Tyrion knew
this Cersei was pregnant then lead him
to questioning the legitimacy of his
supposed child yeah the really funny
thing about Circe's plan is that she's
hinging on the fact that you're on does
not know how to do math if you just give
him a minute he'll figure it out just
gonna take him a second get that hamster
on the wheel just start counting
backwards from nine months like wait a
minute she just told me how could Tyrion
know about it the only time he gives
Cersei a really weird look like he's
questioning her decision is when she
does not kill Tyrion on the spot he just
seems confused about why Cersei would
spare his life instead of killing him on
the spot before Theon died at the Battle
of Winterfell I was hoping that he'd be
the person to kill you're on but now it
sounds like it's gonna be Jaime and it's
gonna have something to do with the way
the Jaime and Cersei wind up going out
next question Sean asks they reference
Starbucks coffee I wonder what it means
the infamous Starbucks cup everyone was
just going on and on about that after
the episode two I'd only watched the
episode once when I made my Episode four
videos so I missed it the first time but
if you know to look for it then you can
actually spot it pretty easily because
it appears during the same scene where
the showrunners Dan and Dave have their
special cameo as wildlings they were the
ones with the beards on they didn't have
any real big speaking lines or anything
like that so it would have been hard to
pick them out unless you look really
really hard or pause the episode the
thing about the copy cup is it as much
of a meme as it turned into HBO actually
released a statement and then within I
would say like a day or so they
digitally replaced the file for the
episode on HBO now an HBO GO
so if Yuri watch the episode now if
they've digitally removed the copy cup
and it's not there anymore usually they
don't do things like that until the DVD
and blu-ray release I think just because
so many people are watching the show
right now they're like we better fix
this really fast next question Agathe
asks if King's Landing is going to be
burned to the ground maybe they'll
change the capital to another city in
future which do you think that would be
well the interesting thing is is that
before Aegon's conquest the capital was
down in Old Town because Aegon is the
one that built King's Landing the reason
why it's called King's Landing is
because at the beginning of Aegon's
conquest of the Seven Kingdoms he
actually brought his armies from
Dragonstone King's Landing is the
location of where his army first made
landfall as they started to march around
the different kingdoms conquering
everyone but the thing about moving the
capital if they needed to if they didn't
want to rebuild King's Landing is that
you would need to put it in a port city
and old town is just like the next best
option is one of the most populous
places in Westeros next to King's
Landing right now next question and
Christina asks do you think that there
will be a surprise seventh episode I
mean there's seven gods Seven Kingdoms
Seven High houses why end it with only
six episodes the interesting thing about
that is that there actually is a seventh
episode but it's more of a bonus episode
it's not like a canonical episode where
the plot moves forward I believe it's
meant to be more of a documentary in a
retrospective on the show doing a little
bit of analysis so it'll air on HBO
you'll get it just like you get all the
other Game of Thrones episodes and it'll
air the week after episode 6 happens I
think what'll happen is is that after
the finale they'll release maybe like a
small promo just reminding people that
they're gonna air it that next week like
surprise there's a bonus episode so I
will do a video for that quote-unquote
episode 7 even though technically it
ends at episode 6
next question Mickey asks I don't
understand Tyrion any more how did he
think that appealing to the sisters
better nature would work it a
never-before is certainly wasn't gonna
start with him siding with Dany so yeah
I agree that nobody thought that Cersei
was gonna do the right thing
so Tyrians family has always been one of
his many great weaknesses usually wine
or his tongue gets him in trouble but
his family is a major weak point so a
lot of people wondering if he's going to
betray Daenerys in some way during the
final two episodes his family would be
one of those weak points that might
cause him to betray her next question
Surya asks do you think that John is
gonna kill Dani in the end I think yeah
that's like a pretty hardcore nuclear
ending the only way I think that happens
is if Danny does go full mad queen or if
John thinks she goes full Mad Queen
right now we're a long ways away from
that so it just depends on how
optimistic or pessimistic or tragic you
think the end of Game of Thrones is
going to be we'll be talking a whole
a lot about this for the next couple of
weeks because obviously we have episode
five then we have whatever the events of
the finale are going to be so don't
worry there'll be many more videos about
what the end game of Game of Thrones is
going to be thank you everyone for so
many questions these are always really
fun to do of course I'll do these for
the next couple of episodes too and
whatever that final bonus episode is
going to be I'm still working on a bonus
video for all the Game of Thrones
prequels that are coming up there's
three that are working on the one that's
called the long night that set during
the Age of Heroes is supposed to start
filming earlier this summer but you may
have also seen them dropped that
watchman HBO trailer that's gonna be
dropping in the fall I will do videos
for the Watchmen TV series I'll try to
do a separate trailer video for that
explaining what the timeline of that is
because I think everybody has a vague
familiarity with it but it's not Game of
Thrones related so it's not really
critical for what's going on this week
and next week leave all your requests
for bonus videos in the comments below
there'll be more later this week
obviously but congratulations - Priya
Singh you're the giveaway winner from my
last big video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 5 trailer video
and click here for my season 8 episode 4
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight